all right donny
yes sir donnie which grew up where are
you from originally
i'm originally from the inland empire of
california like san bernardino san
bernardino county yes sir ontario and
tell me about your family growing up you
had both your parents
um my parents were never there my mom
was a drug addict my dad was a drug
addict and he was always in prison all
my life and my mom was
neglectful to say the least you know um
always
not not being the mother that i needed
really
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um
a lot of a lot of lonely times a lot of
um feeling the need for
you know that parental love that a child
needs you know
and uh i just longing for it it turned
me to the streets
you know and uh
it led to
you know criming drug addiction um
pretty much following right in my
father's footsteps and didn't even
really know it did you join a gang i did
i became i became an ontario skinhead
when i was about 17
and
it didn't take long before that led me
to prison
you know only because my
self-destructive ways were
you know it was a thing like
surrounded by just hatred for you know
people you don't know and really you
just don't understand
and
when you're white and weak in
very i come from
you get preyed upon
by other races and i'm not saying that
they're bad
it's just
you we kind of
we needed we needed
camaraderie and i guess that's what i
was really really looking for and that's
what i found in san bernardino county
with my comrades
you know i
regret a lot of life choices you know
like prison
[Music]
it led me
to a police chase in 2010
i led police on a pursuit
and it ended in ontario with me crashing
into a civilian car
and it left me in critical condition
and i hurt the people that i hit really
bad
and i was sentenced to eight years and
four months in prison for this
and in turn though i suffered greatly i
broke my kneecaps i lacerated my liver
and smashed my gallbladder um a number
of very horrible injuries and
you know
are you in a wheelchair because of that
yes
permanently
well i mean
i i should have gotten better care but
when you're in the prison system medical
is kind of neglected also you don't get
the proper care that you need to get
so my bones kind of set and a surgeon
told me that they would have to re-break
my ankle
and set it again just to even attempt to
fix the damage that i did
you know and um
you know with my drug addiction on top
of that it
needless to say i've i'm haven't been
handling
you know my business like i should have
like you know what is your drug
my drug of choice is fentanyl to this
day uh but before that i struggled with
heroin for 15 years
and before that
i from 13 i just tried crystal meth
ultimately led to heroin at 22 all the
way through my 20s
to 33 now and currently it's fentanyl
that i'm struggling with today
and what happened to the people that you
hit in that accident
um they suffered some serious injuries
um broke
broke their shoulder because i t-boned
the car
broke their shoulder and
three fingers were broken
one so severely that it had to be
surgically taken off
and
you know i felt horrible about that i
never wanted to
i never ever wanted to hurt
a civilian
i wasn't i wasn't really trying to hurt
anybody
but due to
my poor choices and just
just childlike behavior i i hurt an
innocent person really bad and i regret
it to this day
you know i was in critical condition
flat lining on the table but
all in all i look at it like these
people were probably just on their way
to the grocery store and here i come
ruining their day with cops behind me
and in a stolen car it was just it was a
very bad scene and
it's kind of humbled me to this day more
than their day
yeah yeah
more than just their day was ruined i
think yeah of course you know i ruined a
lot more than their day absolutely i've
ruined a good portion of their
you know of their life you know like
that they should have been relaxing in
and
you know i
i just
bombarded them with my
you know
felonious activities
you sound like you've
kind of you feel remorse over it all i
mean did prison give you time to
do that
absolutely absolutely you know i had
once i once i got put in the chair like
this
that was my time to reflect and that's
that was my real prison what was was the
chair more powerful to
yes than the prison time yes
yes
being in the chair
today has actually
made me a better person today i'm
i can honestly say i'm humbled i'm
open to
i'm willing to
engage with you know people of other
races now like you know to like hear
their stories you just even just get to
know someone
whereas i didn't give anybody the chance
before
i can honestly say i
probably consider myself a bad person
before this accident
it kind of opened my eyes in a lot of
ways yeah your demeanor seems
very compassionate and understanding
right now i wonder were you like this
before
the accident before the prison time no
no i am
you know i didn't have
i mean i know it sound it's gonna sound
bad but i mean i guess maybe i didn't
have any respect for human life i didn't
i had no regard for
you know another person's safety due to
my actions and
[Music]
when that happened
i woke up in the hospital
and
like oh my god i couldn't even explain
to you how
how
that felt it felt like being hit by a
train and
i couldn't roll over under my own power
the nurses had to come roll me over my
legs were broken so severely i didn't
even know if i was paralyzed yet
and then all in all i'm thinking
oh my god
did i kill this person that i hit
because when you're when you're
incarcerated like that when they take
you they put you under
a false name for security reasons
and
so that means that you have no contact
with like they're they weren't telling
me nothing i wasn't allowed to read the
paper i was not nothing so i was left
there
wondering if i even killed the person
that i hit
wondering if i even had a chance
at seeing the light of day again
and really ultimately not even being
worried
you know i mean of course i was worried
about my freedom but
it it
it bothered me that i didn't understand
why i was so concerned
about if i had done that to somebody i
didn't even know at the time you know
but
quickly i realized like
like dude
i never filtered in that
i was gonna hurt somebody or that i was
okay well let me put that different
i did
take into consideration that i could
possibly crash into somebody
but the sad thing is i had no respect
for my life either at the time
i never considered living
through the crash
not that i was not that i was like
suicidal or anything i just um
i just expected
that was that was it you know and
when it wasn't
i was left with with a rude awakening
after i woke up out of my coma after two
weeks
you know i woke up
started coming out of
my delirious state and realizing oh wow
i'm in a hospital
i'm shackled to the bed i can't feel my
legs
and then ultimately pieces are coming
back to me remembering what i did
and
yeah i definitely have
i'm i'm remorseful every day for what i
did and i
truly hope that the people i hit
could you know honestly forgive me in
their heart one day you know if they i'm
if they haven't already you know i mean
i'm
if
you know i got to actually see the
person
that i hit in my sentencing
and they give the person a chance to
speak
and right when they right when they did
the lady looked over towards me
and all like i was shackled at my waist
like this and my eyes were black my lip
was ripped open stitches
but all i did was look over and like i
mouthed i'm so sorry i hit you you know
like with tears in my eyes
cause i i
i felt horrible when i
when i seen her come in the courtroom
and it was like i could put a face to
what i'd done you know because i hit a
civilian driver so i had no idea who was
in the car yeah to me that would have
been the most transformative part of
your story
right you know
i just know that you heard an innocent
person out there yeah and that's
something i never wanted to do you know
i've never been about
you know that's um
that's one thing that actually you know
attracted me
with the skinhead movement is
a lot of people think it's surrounded by
hate
and it's really not it's about
like we're about
raising your fam you know raising your
kids
um
you know uh preserving the quality of
your people like a lot of good things
that
are not surrounded by racism so much as
people make it sound
you know it's just nowadays
nowadays the hate just comes from
so many people you're
when you're a different ethnicity you're
you're different that's all it's not i
don't hate you
because you're different
i'm just
interested in my
european lineage my um
my caucasian roots my you know what i
mean but having nothing to hate about
another individual and that's another
thing i educated myself in prison i
you know on other people's cultures
on their ways on their traditions on
their foods like you know like i
actually found myself fascinated by like
i wanted to actually know
like about
you know like i didn't see anything
wrong with
giving yourself knowledge of
another person's
beliefs their traditions their ways i
didn't i didn't see anything wrong with
that and
you know like ultimately the chair is
what what has allowed me to do all that
it made me
a better person ultimately in my heart
and i really feel that
it just sucks that
it took such tragic events
for me to see that
you know
what what do you think
put you on this path
that you were so
destructive self-destructive
before your accident before the
car chase
in prison honestly man i just felt
i don't know if this makes sense but
have could you be in a room with
a thousand people that know you even
and still feel just utterly alone
like i don't know if that makes sense to
you but like i just
like i had
certain figures in my life but
not what i felt i needed i wanted
i don't know i guess i wanted
a mom and dad i wanted the things that
like i seen
other kids have when i was in school or
you know their parents come to these
things like a you know school events um
you see on tv loving families and all
these things and when you come from a
broken home
i mean that's one of the first things
that
get neglected is the like the love and
affection that
that a child ultimately needs you know
like and
[Music]
i guess i see it now that
a person is going to find it
if you're not if you're not getting your
love at home
eventually it's going to move out to the
street
and it's going to be with your peers
it's going to be with
you know who you spend your time with
every day it's going to be who you get
to know
if you don't
if i don't know i guess i could say like
if you don't
curb the problem
ahead of time
you could
turn into a life like mine that's why
i'm actively in my son's life today and
i love my son he's seven
and i'm very much a part of his life and
he's
top of his class he's
very articulate for his age he uses
big words that i even
catch myself like
where did you learn that
and he'll look and thank you like
from you dad
and i'll give him five and i'll be like
oh you did didn't you
you know like
the chairs allowed me to
ultimately i guess wow
ultimately become
like the father that i always wanted
you know like i have my my past and i
have my mistakes but
i'm there every day you know what i mean
i love him i'm i'm actively there i give
him
i make sure
that he never feels the way i did
do you feel like you were loved as a
child
[Music]
not as much as i'd wanted
you know not as much as i wanted
it sounds like that might have been the
core of the problem
i could say that
yeah it's kind of why i don't speak to
my mother and father today
not that there's any bad blood
necessarily it's just
i mean
no no big deal or no i just got nothing
to say you know like i mean it's great
that they got their lives together now
you know
i i i think that's great
it would have been nice
when i you know
you know
they're there for my sister and you know
she's five years younger than me so like
i mean she got to experience the
you know which i i don't
i'm not you know resentful for that or
spiteful for that i just
like like damn like you know i wish you
would
wish you would have tightened the reins
on yourself a little bit sooner you know
what i mean like maybe
i don't know maybe maybe things would
have been different in a better light
maybe
or
maybe
you know i took full responsibility for
what i did and what i've always done
ultimately because i feel that
i did it i
was in the stolen car
that i was driving
it was my decision to take them on the
chase
it was all my fault what happened to me
so i decided
i wasn't gonna be
angry about it i wasn't gonna cry about
it i wasn't gonna
make other people feel pity for me
like i was just gonna man up and i was
just gonna
get through and get on with my life and
that's
what i've attempted to do to this day
what do you worry about
what are you afraid of at this point
you're like
i worry about
my son turning into who i used to be
and then following in the same cycle
that i did do you see any signs of that
with him
no
no
i in no way uh
i in no way like uh
portray my
upbringing the way i was raised uh on
with him
you know i
i
i teach him that
pretty much the exact opposite of that
like
i'm not going to say that i feel
the skinhead movement part is a
bad thing because that's not the part
that i'm
regretting the part that i regret is
not allowing myself to see
the beautiful side of another race
another person
which
you know i've gotten to see
i've gotten to see the good side and the
bad
so
yeah i guess my worst fear is
him turning into me yeah but you're
doing things to prevent that now
i mean i'm trying my all right no i
can't even i can't i'm not trying my
best but i am
[Music]
i am
i make cause very conscious decisions
about everything i do everything i say
around him every you know every
every example i lead
you know
and i think i am on the right track
because i mean
he says please he says thank you he says
excuse me this is all seven years old
you know and he's been doing this for
quite a few years now you know i've
i've instilled in him
the the things that
my grandmother
is the reason my grandmother my
grandfather the reason that i am
even
half a man or you know individual like i
am today like you knows because of them
that i
can speak well when the time permits or
you know just have to the
common decency or common sense to
say excuse me if i uh
burped in public or you know something
just like um
something that i guess you would say
like a the charming etiquette thing to
do would be like you know you know you
say excuse me like like oh shoot like
you know
just little things like that i make sure
that
i want i want his i want his mind to
always be open to
like
there's no reason you have to hate
somebody like that
you know and
[Music]
i
i don't know
you know
i guess
i mean yeah i feel what i'm doing
is like i'm on the right path
you know now if i could i know what my
problems are
if i could get a hold of my drug
addiction
i know my life would be beautiful
i just
i thought i'd found true happiness with
my son's mom and
seven years in she
changes her mind
so to speak and
left me for another man and
you know that kind of left me
i
was horrible you know like so now i sit
you know on the single father side of it
now and
still
struggling myself now to find like i
thought that was my
i thought we were supposed to be
together forever like i thought that's
who
you know like i found my soul mate and
you know like i was happy and
but ultimately like people get stale in
their relationships i guess
and i think that's what happened i lost
sight of like
i we turned into different people
and i don't know if that was for good or
for the bad but
i mean it's
definitely shaping life's experiences
today you know like it's gonna
only time will tell now
i'm not looking for a relationship but
i mean if somebody comes along like i'm
not afraid of it like i would embrace it
but
you know like
i was just left with that lonely feeling
again you know like and it was like all
like all over again but in a different
sense if that makes any sense at all
you know like that
that dark empty feeling of loneliness
came back and
that's
why i'm on the streets of l.a and
you know
smoking my sorrows away and fentanyl and
trying to figure it all out again
you're living on the streets now yeah
yeah are you in a tent or
no not at the moment
no just wake up
yeah just kind of
suck it up and you know just get through
the night how do you support yourself
um i mean honestly i panhandle right now
you know
ask people
for spare change
you know
it's not because i'm a lazy person or
anything it's just
the damage i did to myself is
um so substantial that
i've
it's like the humbling thing i said like
i've been able to humble myself to ask
another individual for change
other than
my old
my old ways before my accident
i you know would i wouldn't even
worry about doing harm to a person to
take their wallet or something like that
you know that's a that's a horrible way
to think
that's a horrible way to be
so i thought i was making the right
decision
just humbling myself to panhandle i
guess right but that's
anyway that's how i
support myself right now a
panhandle from day to day and how's your
emotional state
today
you know it's rocky man i have my uh
i have my
like i have okay days most of the days
you know it's
more or less like i guess i just put on
a little mask and like uh
i can smile through
what i'm really going through i guess
but i mean
the smile is a facade you know it's it's
just for show like i'm
i'm not happy i'm not happy at all
you know i do love my life but
i'm not happy with it
maybe i just have to learn
[Music]
to really really
be comfortable with me
and
everything about me you know like
like if i can't be comfortable with
myself then
how could i expect somebody else to i
guess
you know
yeah
tell me about the face tattoos when were
those done
uh they started about
two years into my term um
see like when you're 22 and you get
sentenced to eight years
that literally feels like the rest of
your life
even though it's not
you know when i when i got through the
end of it i was like
whoa it's already like wow five years
has gone by and i couldn't believe it
but
when i started doing that
i didn't
i didn't see myself going home
i thought that
i thought that that was going to be my
future
and
[Music]
i
i do regret them in a sense
like
you know i do love tattoos
it's not that um
i just regret
where i got them
you know
the quality of how they're done um
and
i guess
people tell me i have a
scary demeanor
until i speak
and
i didn't get that for a long time
like because i always feel like
like i'm one of the coolest dudes you'll
ever meet i'm i'm laid back i'm
you know
i've been told i'm funny trump whatever
you want however you know i've been told
good things about myself from other
people
whether i saw those good things in
myself or not you know that's what i've
been told
you know and
like i had somebody tell me one time
like it's not that you
look stupid or anything
i was just like what i just don't look
smart
and they laughed and they were like well
yeah
and they said because a normal person
doesn't do that to their face
and i was like
right
i mean i don't know what could i say at
that point because that's
that's a true statement you know like
when if you put me in a room with
20 even 30 random people
i'd be willing to bet money on it that
i have the most tattooed face in the
room
and
that kind of makes me uh
extra noticeable in good ways and bad do
you get judged just absolutely
absolutely
constantly
where where i could just be saying good
morning to a stranger as i'm passing
them you know and i only say it because
maybe i'm rolling past them and i'm a
little
i'm probably overthinking it but i'm a
little
close for their comfort maybe
so i just you know good morning and but
i just get this look like
like
like turn your nose down at me type of
look like
like this
thing
you know and i
i get it but i don't get it
you know what i mean because like
i looked at it like wow i mean even if i
look like this right i mean
i feel i've made a lot of positive
changes over the years so i mean
am i always gonna have a bad stigma for
like the tattoos on my face or
are people gonna
like let their guard down for lack of a
better word and you know accept that
like hey people change all the time
i could change too
the only thing that can't change is
the permanent ink that i've put under my
skin that's all
you know my heart's in a different place
now like
even if i still look the same yeah you
see you seem like a reformed person
it's a shame the tattoos kind of drag
you back into the past life you had
i think that's a fair assessment you
know i i
i'd agree with that very much
very much
you know sometimes my tattoos get
glorified by people like like like oh
that's so cool like
not even having anything to do with the
prison
[Music]
sentence but
95
98 of the time
i mean they're socially acceptable now
more than ever
but they weren't always
i mean if somebody had even the smallest
tattoo on their face that was uh
that was a convict thing that was a
prison thing and
you know that's what people always
associated it with
so i mean even if
i could be a tattoo artist fully
reformed today
and i'm still gonna have people look at
me like a convict that wants to snatch
their purse or do them harm
harm to people they love and that's not
the case
but
i mean people are going to be people i
guess
johnny what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
the most important lesson i've learned
out of this is that there's more out of
life than
just getting high and
trying to curb the pain
like
i guess i believe now that
if we all could just bring ourselves to
man up for lack of a better word and
face the
issues at hand
there wouldn't really be issues anymore
and
you could
move on and
[Music]
continue on with your life and not have
these
again for lack of a better
traumatic experiences that you fall back
on to
you know like things that set off a
traumatic experience or like uh
i don't know somebody's parents fighting
all the time in their broken dishes so
you're old lady drops a glass and
that could trigger something and remind
somebody of something like that
um
i believe now that
if i would have given myself
if i would have loved myself
enough
to
give myself the real fighting chance at
life that i that i deserved
that i should have given myself
my life would have turned out
great
like to this day i want to go to the la
school of music i would love to
you know i
love music i
you know want to be a professional beat
maker i make beats in my spare time i uh
you know i'm
working on you know getting a personal
business off the ground like i'm you
know actually trying to do something of
substance today
and
[Music]
i want to
have something
to leave my son
and
at least when i go
let him see like hey
no matter daddy's past or
anything you may hear that's
damaging to my reputation as dad
at least he'll know like one of the last
things that i was trying to do
was something
to ultimately leave to him you know i
wanted to
i wanted him to see the aid
you know dad wasn't out just screwing up
like some of my family members
put in his ear
i don't agree with it i don't think it's
right you know
i
i would never
bad mouth them
to my son the way they do me and
that's a frustrating thing
because he'll tell you himself that
i'm a great dad and i'm his best friend
and that means something to me
all right donnie
thank you so much for sharing your story
yes sir thank you for letting me speak
um
i actually feel really good about
getting that out i haven't
i haven't spoke that freely about myself
in a long time
excellent i wish you the best of luck
thank you very much sir i appreciate you
thank you
you